this is the grill for you I called it
the Obama come on say amaz my Elmo the
boy
I call this - big black machine oh my
god do you smell gas a little bit came
out but how's the nervous that's just a
quick you're the best salesman I've ever
seen I can see you being a stockbroker
like me can't you give me a job I wish I
could my boss won't let me hire I
dropped out look at Mark Zuckerberg he
dropped out of Harvard you dropped out
or Piedmont high that was a couple
credits shy of graduating I got to get
my GED I'm the principal of this school
I can do whatever I want
yo ran my house
are you using a black voice no I don't
hear color alright let's do some
introductions my name is Carrie I'm here
to make a little extra cash so that I
can afford this morning that I got but
that's none of our business
welcome to night school this book is
kind of thick I thought it'd be more
like a leaflet it's not gonna do the
work drop the class no I'm gonna do the
work you'll see we'll see
yes we will great superb excellent good
[Music]
you're gonna be a financial analyst I am
gonna start immediately I have been
waiting on the Lord to bring me a
pint-sized little man who can fill this
out let me get you chicken from the Lord
you take that test my tender Raja where
are you trying to get your TV are you
trying to get your GED yes you can get
out my way being
my suspicions were correct oh you're
clinically them there is no cure for
what you have oh my god I got learning
herpes I got the gift that people give
it boy you did the black boys thing we
had it's not a black voice not a black
voice you don't remember when you was in
that meeting he was like we gonna get it
lit up and hear this meeting lit it was
very lit I keep it 100 when have I ever
not kept it 100
you